[Music]
the NFL plays a nearly Full Slate of
Saturday games later today including
some right here on CBS in addition to
watching The Game's millions of fans
will be betting on them Sports wagering
is now legal in more than 30 States and
Washington DC with more states on the
way in 2023 gamblers risk an estimated
one billion dollars each week of the NFL
season and that's just one sport
oddsmakers are taking bets on just about
anything with a ball and as we learned
the wagering is becoming intertwined
with the games themselves
on a Wednesday afternoon in Pittsburgh a
journeyman catcher step to the plate
strike to Tyler heinemann but even this
low-stakes baseball moment had people
betting on what Tyler would do next he's
about four to one to strike out five to
one to hit a single in fanduel's New
Jersey office Trader Tom Heenan tweaked
the odds while his boss will twin looked
on and this is a big part of what we try
and do we want to give a really
Innovative betting experience for our
customers
okay he walked someone had walked
someone did at 13-1 oh that's pretty
good they turned their 100 into 1300 for
a walk
Sports bets used to be placed in Las
Vegas before the game started the odds
or point spreads were never discussed
during the broadcast and don't forget to
play fanduels over under game four now
in-game betting made from a phone what
you need to do is download the BET MGM
Sportsbook app is promoted seemingly
constantly he scored a touchdown in
eight of the last 10 games Mike
raffensberger is fanduel's Chief
marketing officer I personally think
there may be no more disruptive force in
sports than gaming and you must think
that's a good thing I think it's an
excellent thing and by the way we're the
official Sportsbook of the NFL the NBA
the NHL we have a long-standing
partnership with MLB the WTA the PGA the
league think so too it's a remarkable
reversal for the leagues just 10 years
ago they sued New Jersey to stop Sports
gaming here's NFL commissioner Roger
Goodell five years ago we still strongly
oppose of legalized Sports gambling but
in 2018 the Supreme Court ruled New
Jersey and other states could legalize
sports betting I think there were a good
amount of people that were that were
shocked Darren Revell who covers the
industry for the sports Gaming website
the Action Network says leagues that
once insisted betting would compromise
the Integrity of their Sports have
adopted a new position that gambling
supercharges fan engagement it does seem
a little bit insane how you could so
oppose something and then now you're
fully into it why do you think the
switch it's just it's just money Pirates
at -124 the money is flowing into
sponsored pre-game segments and in
stadium Billboards and naming rights
it's flowing into commercials I think
Boston's going to cover why you know
something I know and more commercials
you know what to do and more and more
and more commercials these glass is
solid gold the bet is that there's going
to be losers here and that's why you
know this is a good business I need
another tutty out of him for 7.50 it's
not looking too good right now at
fanduel's new facility inside the
Mohegan Sun Casino in Connecticut
even a brick and mortar sports book has
a different feel
pics that win or lose in a matter of
minutes this is going to be a bet on
what's going to happen next first
touchdowns for it all right even with
bedding windows and kiosks right there
many fans still buried in the app they
could use at home Jaguars Morning Line
Trevor over and everywhere parlays these
are bets that have a lot going on in
them yeah that's right bets that require
many picks to all go right 17 Leger no
17 legs I mean come on you might as well
buy a lottery ticket Sports books now
heavily promote these exotic bets you
can win a lot of money on a small bet
the long odds benefit the house
fans like how much excitement you can
buy for a few dollars do you do this for
money or do you
do it for fun but they're also quick to
bring up those rare Magic occasions he
hit five during the NBA season win 20
bucks turned into something like 4 600.
what do you remember about that night I
was sweating pacing around
my I lost 500 the next day
in the front row of the sports book we
found Kenny Ackerman self-described
lifelong Gambler from Connecticut who
can final legally bet on Sports in his
home state this didn't exist like really
recently it's a whole different world
dude what do you make of that uh I think
it's bad for society I mean I like it
it's fun but I think overall access to
all these apps and gambling sites on the
Internet is people get addicted to it
and I think they they gamble too much
and it's going to hurt a lot of people
we know from history the more access
people have to gambling the more problem
gamblers we're gonna have why should
people be excited about the expansion of
this thing that we know is going to lead
to bad outcomes for many people so I
challenged maybe the the Assumption in
the question betting was happening
before legal regulated American
companies were running it we really
operate under a principle that this is a
form of entertainment and it should be
fun and have put a ton of effort around
responsible gaming efforts those efforts
include sponsoring a weekly Radio Show
in New York devoted to responsible
gaming my story in personal history with
gambling has been well documented but
that won't outweigh the impact of all
the gambling hype out there now we have
this on FanDuel already you can bet this
according to gambling addiction
counselor Rick Benson and what we are
seeing not surprisingly many of these
young gamblers are as addicted to their
cell phone as they order the gambling
Benson was a problem Gambler himself but
overtime has found it possible to safely
enjoy sports I still make get a point to
stay away from point spreads those
spreads and money lines are none of my
business it's hard to watch a game now
though without seeing them on the screen
do you think that's a problem for
gamblers in recovery I think it's a
problem for gamblers who are still
gamblers and and some gamblers in
recovery absolutely I think it's a
problem but it's unlikely to change so
let's take a look at FanDuel Sportsbook
Live point totals One gaming executive
described the situation to us as a
prisoner's dilemma pushing sportsbooks
leagues and broadcast networks
into ever more aggressive marketing the
touts and everyone else have been
disingenuous about losing have not
talked overtly about bankroll just
because you can live bet something and
it's available doesn't mean you should
do it I also have a different parlay
money line
there does seem to be a little bit of
pushback California had two ballot
measures in November they both failed so
gambling will not be legal there I like
the guy in the front of the sports book
who you talked to who's been betting his
whole life he says and he's like I don't
think it's a good idea gambling the
point is it's so much easier now yeah
it's the debate if you don't have time
to get into it's really a fascinating
debate between making it so much easier
and the problem that it can be